THE PLAYOFFS OF THE HE'S BEENESE
BAT
[ HORN ]
>> F FINALIST
MAKING THE CASE AS HE WALKS IT
STRAIGHT AWAY LINEUP.
>> FOR THE NASHVILLE
PREDATORS -- COGLIANO IN FRONT.
SS
RITTICH.
MANSON WITH THE WRISTER, NICE S.
LAST NIGHT IT WENT IN.
HERE'S TOEWS ON THE NEAR SIDE.
BACK UP TOP, MacKINNON WIDE
NOBODY HOME FOR THE PREDS.ORES.
MATT DUCHENE FAR POST.
>> I'VE WATCHED DUCHENE.
MacKINNON AND HE WILL SHOOT IT
AND A SAVED BY RITTICH.
COMES BACK TO NATHAN
MaMa THE NET!
[ HORN ]DER.
WATCH THE NASHVILLE
GIRARD.
AT THE POINT, KEEPS IT ALIVE. JT
THREW IT ON THE ICE LOOKING FOR.
FIRST DUCHENE AND N SCORE!
RICOCHETED OFF J.T. COMPHER.
AVS AREHER THE
AVALANCHE DESPERATELYEAD BY MAN.
BACK TO THE FRONT. NEW -- JOSI
DOWN THE CREASE AND THEGO OFF TD
IN?
>> NO, I THINK FROM THE ANGLE W.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S
HERE'S MacKINNON, COUGHS IT
BACKHAND WIDE TO THE NET.
GY TRYING T HIGH-PROFILE --
>> SCORE RIGHT OFF THE DRAW,
EKHOLM WIRES ONE IN ANDT THIS P.
THERE. T
MOSE WE'VE SEEN IT FOR YEARS.
ES.
DUCHENE SHOOTS SEASON.